Speaker 1: But don't worry, it's not
just major corporations that are guilty
of greed here in the United States.
Congress has a very serious problem.
With using their insider knowledge to buy and
sell stocks. We have seen the reports, you know,
a Business Insider earlier this year or
maybe even early last year, whatever it was,
64 members of Congress in the last two years
have violated the STOCK Act. Almost 200 of their
staffers have also violated the STOCK Act. And
of course, these individuals have information.
They've got budget information. They know where
money's going to be spent before it gets spent.
And they can use this information. To buy
stocks. They can use it to sell stocks.
And a majority of Americans, 70% of them, to be
exact, say they want a ban on congressional stock
trading. 50% of Republicans and 45% of Democrats
say they're actually going to be more likely
to vote for a candidate if they support a ban on
politicians trading stocks. I personally, you may
think it's a little extreme. I want to go further
than just banning them, buying and selling stocks.
I don't think they should be allowed to own them.
Sorry again. That's just me. You can disagree.
That's fine. Doesn't matter. Doesn't bother me.
But you're choosing a life of public service.
You've got to give those things up. They
made Jimmy Carter sell his peanut farm.
Now he had to sell his peanut farm.
I don't think it's too far fetched to
say that members of Congress should
have to sell their Raytheon stock.
Not a blind trust. I want it banned. They
can't own it at all. But I would also settle
if this is the best case scenario with a ban
on them buying and selling it. And so what,
of course, 70% of the American public. And the
biggest problem is this stock act that all these
congresspeople keep violating, Democrats and
Republicans alike. It's a bipartisan issue.
You know, the penalty is for violating
it. $200 fine if the fine is even,
you know, put in place, sometimes they waive the
fine. So you could trade $50,000 worth of stock.
You could buy 50,000, you know,
profit, ten, 20, 30%, whatever it is.
You can make ten, 20, $30,000 off of it.
And the only penalty you have is a $200 fine
for violating the STOCK Act at that point. That's
not a fine. That's just a fee for doing business.
Listen, that's all the time we have for
today's show. We've got some great stuff com